most of those rescued are being held
here at the reception and identification
center on the island of course it's
currently being expanded to accommodate
more refugees
we were allowed to film the rescued
passengers from a distance but not to
talk to them even though they've all
tested negative for covert 19 the greek
centers for disease control mandates
that they spend two weeks in quarantine
after that they'll be allowed to apply
for asylum here
they were weary after spending three
days at sea but they also seemed
relieved their misery was over
some have mobility problems we gave them
water food first aid and we're looking
for clothing for them
their journey here was an ordeal and an
accident they set out from turkey
heading for italy but their ship lost
power and they called for help
this is how the greek coast guard found
them adrift on the aegean sea they then
told them 750 kilometers to cost the
nearest reception center where they
could be processed
according to aegean boat report an ngo
that monitors refugee boats that tow
lasted almost three days because the
murat was dragged back and forth greek
authorities say that's because they were
trying to get turkey to accept the boat
back
we sent two requests to the turkish
authorities but they never responded
they responded just after
we had this ship already in the port of
cost
mainly we were asking whether this ship
is turkish or not and if it is turkish
it should be whether we should return
that to the turkish
sea
border
irregular migration has become a
sensitive issue between greece and
turkey under a 2016 agreement turkish
authorities are supposed to prevent
refugees from entering the european
union but in march of last year turkey
actively encouraged refugees to storm
greek borders ever since then aid groups
allege greek authorities have often
tried to prevent potential asylum
seekers from entering greek territory
such pushbacks are illegal under the
geneva convention on the status of
refugees the passengers of the murat 729
were caught in the intensifying politics
of border management john saropolos
al-jazeera goss